so
hello hello everyone how is it going
hopefully you can hear me today we are
playing some
call of duty black ops cold war beta
action it's been a while since i've been
here with you guys on
a gamespot live it's exciting to be back
and to play some cod
and also i got the homie richie in the
chat you guys
okay you guys you know it is my rng
that my whole exploit would crash right
as we were starting
so let's try this again hey all right
okay now you guys should be able to hear
richie what's
what is up let us know i'm gonna give
i'm gonna give this stream a couple of
minutes to maybe like catch up to itself
give a few seconds for our viewers to uh
you know maybe refresh hopefully we're
back
let us know it looks good
all right awesome hopefully uh guys let
me know if you can hear richie oh
sorry my mic volume is now 100 even
though i had it down to like
40 before it crashed but it's fine
okay guys what is good i see you in the
chat thank you so much for waiting
and being patient the beta is here
guys what we're gonna be playing a whole
new map today
um the new mode isn't out until next
week i believe correct me if i'm wrong
richie or a chat let me know
um but yeah we were definitely hype
about the new mode but it's not gonna be
available until next week so
i think we will be back next week for
some more action when we are able to
play that mode so
i'm actually pretty excited um but yeah
we got a new map
and then we're gonna check it out new
quality of life updates too
like it should be running a lot smoother
oh nice i unfortunately missed out on my
chance to try the alpha
um actually i think i got to play like a
very few handful of games but like when
i mean try it out you want to be able to
like sit down and play it for its
entirety and i didn't get a chance to do
that last time so
so yeah i'm excited okay
so featured mode
what's the name of the new map again i
want to make sure i'm in going into the
right playlist
was it oh uh there's there's cartel and
quick play modes and then
i think there might be another one for
combined arms like a whole different one
gotcha i think well cartel's in both
so let's warm up with with death match
because
lord knows i need to warm up you guys
so we're searching we're in we've
pressed play yes the new map is cartel
and i got one round in and like couldn't
even pick like my own gun because you
know
create a class isn't unlocked yet yeah
see that's the upside
right to um starting off in the beta
like real early with everyone else is
we're all stuck with the the pre-made
classes and the pre-made loadouts
is that your slack no it's not it's mine
i'm sorry
oh no i shoulda i'm closing slack uh
sorry jlt if something's imploding i'm
sorry
but yeah
oh snap we are in and we're going to
moscow
i've never been i've never been this map
is fun
i think is the open beta available for
everyone
so it is but i think there's different
times that the
beta is available per platform so if you
want to know like
wherever your pre-order got your beta
accessed then you guys should go to
gamespot.com plug plug plug
and then um you know find that
information out because we got
all of that wow this is very cinematic
for the start i like it quite the
opening yeah
aaron in the chat thank you aaron for
the clarification
i'm just trying to you know get my get
my mind prepared
um you know to bust some guns hopefully
we can get aaron in here too to play
with us
richie and aaron are the game spot cod
veterans they do all of our cod stuff if
you want to watch
cod like content and learn about
everything
just go to our channel because aaron and
richie they are holding it down
okay focus time
let me think cold-blooded scavenger
that's good but i don't want that big
old gun
hmm decisions decisions
i'm gonna go with this one i'm gonna try
this one out this means i i feel like i
have to run a gun with this because the
gun looked
very tiny we're in there
let's go
oh man my settings are wrong
i'm gonna die trying to fix this aren't
i
i did where is it
did i miss this button layout oh there
it is
okay
we're going to confirm those kills let's
go
[Laughter]
breaking glass over here i don't
bear with me guys it's going to be
i've been playing too many scary games
so now my jumpscares are just off the
charts
i've been playing that phasmaphobia game
which is
amazing by the way yes
because you know me i'm a modern day
ghost hunter
not really i'm actually too scared to do
it in real life that's why i was excited
they finally made a game
odin
mr mcdaddy avenge me bro
there's one chasing you richie yeah
oh you got him you got him oh i'm
getting flash
that was not a tactical that was a
stencil but
i'll take that oh there's a ping system
in here now right richie
yeah if you press instead of up on the
deep head on the d-pad
oh my gosh i thought it was going to be
a more useful button but
no yeah that's pretty bad
it's fine though i mean they can't
really replace
it with you know right for like
apex and stuff because
i'm so bad oh
i missed like 30 shots
it's all about the tags no worries i
know right i've also i also don't think
i've confirmed a single one of my girls
either but
that's it that's how the cookie crumbles
sometimes
oh see this gun i got it i should have
like
stealth ran up to him and then tried to
kill him i was trying to long range it
ain't gonna happen are you trying the ar
also
um i'm using like this little tiny oozy
looking gun
why didn't i look both ways before i
cross the road
rookie mistake
that i wanted instead of this one
i was trying to pick up those tags but
then
yeah it didn't happen because someone's
out there and i was scared
yeah that's a technique for sure just
camping over tags
my audio is like all confused oh that's
my teammate
i don't know where they're coming from
my guess is
up here i'm trying to ping yeah there we
go
i didn't oh no
i don't want to know where they are but
like they're not over here anymore
did we switch spawns oh we switched up
no no spawn camping us
well it's not my turn but team effort
i didn't pick up
whoa okay
enemies buy a plane do i have ghosts on
this class because that would be nice
mission timeline expired rtb
all right i confirmed to kill guys let's
go
someone's behind me i hate that when
you're like running from looking
somewhere and then you hear gunshots
coming from your direction
what is this oh
yes
someone went over here i think
or we switched ones that could be a
thing too yeah
yeah we definitely did retreat
i hear a lot of explosions
[Music]
okay good thing he didn't shoot me or
else that would have been dangerous
did i one oh no i thought i had the kill
streak already
i was so close i think i actually don't
even know what killstreaks i have i just
yeah there are default ones like i think
artillery uav and
like stealth chopper dang i felt like i
was close
i think i was like on nine or something
yeah so fast isn't it i feel like it's
pretty
it's longer than the typical cod i feel
like i'll still spy players
i was probably just getting melted
are you using the ar yeah i'm using the
mp5 and the fire rate seems pretty uh
pretty good for just the range is not
good just doing this knockout obviously
i say as i try to engage in a long range
fight
oh got him i killed mr
turkey oh snap it's not thanksgiving yet
well he got roasted
oh yeah
oh whoa whoa all right everybody
and uh their mama's in the checkered
room
whoa that guy okay this guy is like he's
over it
he's my definitely
doing all kinds of wonky things right
no no yeah i lived somebody got the last
kill before i
died let's go
oh mr turkey got the best play though
oh
top of the leaderboard who me
oh my gosh i'm pressing all the wrong
buttons right now guys
i'm gonna make my exploit crash again
delete the team
okay we went up three levels in that
game guys that's not bad
not at all now we can probably mess
around with our class or something
load out no not yet kill streaks or
class
create a class is unlocked at oh it
doesn't say
never it's just a beta
interesting i'm like looking through the
after action report
had all the medals and stuff yeah it's
pretty cool
yeah all right so i unlocked it looks
like the m16
all right let me see
i can't even view oh no i can i'm in the
wrong tab
or am i what is happening
oh here we go
default class four
ooh
wait why am i stuck in this screen
where are we oh we started a game i was
like no don't crash
um what is good what is good chat sorry
i'm like oh dean we're in miami now we
went
we're all over traveling all over the
world
um yeah what's good brandon what's good
saw cyberpunk mendoza
joshua everybody what's up
rcxd
oh yeah never left oh
that proves how much i've been playing
the recent like war zone and stuff
oh yeah black ops uh every every black
ops game
has like had that's probably like the
one thing they've all had is
an rcxt but warzone did not
we're gonna hop in the pool guys
oh man i would like this gun but i do
not like this cgi you are cleared hot
me either the m16 yeah i like how you
knew which one i was talking about was
that
we are pulling ahead oh nice so let me
change
oh this is a corner oh no
the classic like when you play a map for
the first time you're like i'll run away
this way
into nowhere yeah
someone's right around here
oh no okay that's richie oh
i'm no good with um
three round burst i do like that gun i
just definitely
oh oh oh my god
nice someone else got it for me we are
in the league
it sounded like a shotgun that close
yeah i was like
my
i face they're over there they're over
there oh no wait i'm trying to use the
ping
how dare you level four let's go
oh he got me with the rc car
oh no see confirmed it's bad
oh my goodness oh my goodness justice
fever what is up
nah bro nah what are you doing
oh god what am i doing he's dead winning
by one point
i'm struggling to get away from this van
yeah
i saw someone over there
[Music]
sorry bro
wow this area is actually really big
i don't know why i was thinking this
left side that i'm in right now it was
like
a shallow area but there's actually a
lot of space back here
you got the whole beach over there
you can go oh yeah
artillery standing by
take a dip you guys yeah refreshing
it was quite refreshing i'm not gonna
lie all right
there was a glitch where you could jump
on the diving board and like jump
super hard
or on my same level i should say
okay
phew thank goodness for that spy plane
see some dude was at the at the diving
board again
[Music]
i wish i had a rocket in this class no
rockets yet
give me your gun yeah
i think i need to take a dip after that
one
oh got him behind you dude no
i didn't get either of them i was like
this is an easy double
but i dropped a combo
no worries
there's a lot of places to go in this
map look how nice this is
wow yeah that spot you're talking about
is the best place for us
oh i see because there's like a wall huh
yeah
dang justice beaver got his revenge
avenge me survivor
willie's grotto nice
i like this map a lot me too
sliding is so anti-climatic
yeah i'm sure it was nerfed it was
really bad
no there's two of them there
they're definitely coming this way
though
nice
yeah the recoil on my gun is a pretty
mess
it like looks like it shakes a lot but
it actually is like
pretty accurate i like that math
it was very color i think it's my
favorite so far yeah
i like it because it was like visually
stunning you know oh okay we can
customize classes
there now go okay hold up i think let's
back out
back at this ring
rockets launchers here we go
launches
reliable damage with improved fire rate
i mean it's never bad to have a class
with a
good straightforward gun oh wait
i've realized i'm not even going to be
able to change any of this yeah
because we don't even have anything
unlocked
deal it you're right well
it looks like some of the well whatever
let's just play another one man yeah not
even the lethal or tactical
nothing let's do
let's do quick play again
sweet
oh you're right i did have the gas mine
i haven't even used it yet
i'll try to use it next game there's
like a lot to absorb right now
yeah like in three okay it's like you
know cod cuts like
you know cod is caught but then they
always like throw in these little things
and you're like oh wait yeah i have to
remember i have to ping now
and like oh yeah you know can't forget
to use my stem cell
and oh cartel the new one
let's do it voting
oh man this is this one's already
reminding me of
that one map that they had i don't even
remember which card it was but
they had a hanger like this on the left
and then there was that big circle silo
thing
on the right and then oh and caught four
that one was it good for sniping it kind
of was if you were in the hangar
and you were like sniping people running
in from the outside
yeah i think i think i remember the one
you're talking about
yo i am excited for zombies so
i was talking about zombies i was like
you're right they are oh
i totally am ready for some zombies
ooh i like the flowers nice car
anybody shoots that car you're gonna
have to pay for the damages
you will be yes
yeah new map time
um you know i'm gonna stick with this
milano gun
cause it's kind of been holding the dumb
can you confirm they added the ping
system they did so they've moved the
ping
from the down d-pad button to the left
d-pad button which
i guess after trying to use it it was
kind of a little better
but obviously it won't be as intuitive
as like right bumper but
we can't replace right bumper in this
game
in warzone they changed the load they
changed it so that it was right bumper
but i defaulted back
up on the d-pad exactly because it's
like he needs to be able to
throw your needs defend our freedom
that's how i film but that's why in like
apex they're sacrificing the ease of
like throwing your grenades
yeah with the pink system so it's like
i ran all the way over here not looking
for a single soul and i didn't die so
this is a good sign so far i think oh
oh man i looked in every wrong direction
both of you died next to me and i looked
in every wrong direction
you were like surrounded
oh he saw me i went in the wrong bush
that's what it was
oh no should have went in the other bush
oh no this is bad ow
i also slid right into a grenade
um whoa my orientation okay here we go
it's like
hard to get a grasp on when i'm near the
edge of the map or not which
is really weird
kill denied dang it shoot enemy spy
plane
i got my rocket for it yeah
we come prepared
whoa what's my expect now let's scoop up
these times
so okay i confirmed like three kills
right there i think
that's what it's all now yeah objective
boys
i was like last in the last time we
played pool confirmed but i was the
highest and
confirmed just lowest kills that's why
we want you know
oh man if i could just not miss every
single bullet
that would be so sick that would be
so awesome you know oh my god
that was him that was super hand
okay wait so l1 and r1 is my gas thing
right
try that out i'm gonna try to put it in
the bushes
like right here behind me oh yes
just mine going down somebody's let's go
oh stop stop
they're over there i'm stunned
that first shot didn't even hit him
artillery targeting detective
i wouldn't account
level five
oh he's in this tower
legit think i ran into their spawn i
didn't even know
that that is my logic in a nutshell
y'all need to go somewhere
okay let's just act like no one saw that
the stream went down
what i don't know something no
no
i got him before i died though i'll take
that trade i got my kill streak
we're in there it counts
yeah exactly
i threw that third one in the worst spot
but i was just panicking
out
oh sunshine
what what there's a million people in
here
by this little sniper tower in the back
oh i'm bugging y'all saw that i saw a
reflection of something in the water and
i thought it was a person
of course
[Applause]
oh my gosh
of course i ran right
[Music]
no i can't see let's go
oh
oh my god look at this guy oh i got
zapped man
no stay inside guys
get out of here oh
chopper's down yeah oh reliable richie
in the clutch
love my rockets
dang sounds like they do too i heard all
kinds of stuff
oh man i should have sniped him
enemy spy plane inbound dang it
i've like forgotten how to knife after
all these games that show no less than
they live
yeah i don't resort to knifing anymore
it's like it's so good in cod too
also artillery targeting active i
remember when people used to be
mad about people who would quote unquote
panic nights i'm like what do you want
somebody
to die
for a while it was really bad with like
commando
oh man
oh i'm definitely all up in there
in their basement
can make this come back
oh my gosh oh my gosh we're cleaning up
we're cleaning up we're cleaning up tags
oh i scooped up like four or five tags
right there at the end i was trying so
hard
you got a lot oh look at dad
look at dad bodying the both of us in
the play of the game
really that was the best play just him
killing both of them okay i was about to
say i was like i hope
we see a few more yeah because if that
was the best one
richie we got some explaining to do
yeah i don't know about that
level six let's go
me too and unlock
the rcxd in the stem shot 26 and 17.
last 10 games played only played like
three so far
for four yeah i think three
so i mean for me so far i definitely
like it
because it's like no it's caught it's
like
drinking water it's like you already
know what it's gonna be
you know what's gonna be you know good
for you
so yeah yo dwayne johnson
in the party
i mean they smell they spelled johnson
wrong but it's okay we take those
we could just assume that when the rock
actually tried to sign up for his psn it
was already taken
obviously so he had to switch up
spelling a little bit to join us
yep so this is the official one exactly
exactly
satellite
i'm officially out of coffee and i'm sad
that's fine
need one more player
let's see if i unlocked anything
level 13 is there a cap on the level
in the beta like there was an um
there was another one we were playing
that i think it might just be 10
10 okay i think that's when you get the
blueprint i think that's when it stops
dang this is like kind of like creepy
sad
ominous like the satellite just crashed
oh yeah it's a fun map though
so i used to gas mine a couple of times
last game but i didn't stay around it
long enough to find out
if um
it killed anybody or what it did i kept
running around
oh yeah i haven't really used that yet
here we go
dang when are we going to be able to
drive those much
i know i think they were teasing that
fire team dirty bomb trailer too
would be cool to have like team races
and stuff
okay
all right so this is the chokepoint
clearly
everybody emerged like anne
oh i'm bad watch out in your left behind
us they're going around
oh i see them one's back there too
there's two of them
let's i thought i was going to fall
damaged myself to death because i was
really
low
behind oh xm4 level that
i feel like i always hear people and i
can't pinpoint where they are
enemy appears thank you
they're all here i should have kept
running why am i so
greedy that's what cod does to me cod
just makes me feel like yeah i can 1v7
everyone why not even my own team let's
go
if you go off to the left yeah
i can see them trying to like take over
this spot
what from the dunes
okay we've officially switched on so
watch out
on the other side yep they're coming
through
what just three frank woods over there
no i'm so close
killing it i just panicked because i
knew someone was coming up there
losing this fight
that's good news
over here
no i should i shouldn't go out that far
with this gun i have to like hide behind
stuff i'm playing ring around the rosie
with this guy
oh i knew it
oh man i see him over there but
oh i killed dwayne johnson no hostile
rcxd in your eo
i'm bad i'm so bad i cannot
control this tiny little gun
oh no oh no i saw it coming over the
hill
above me i guess oh i couldn't tell
can you get on top of that thing on top
of the little mountains
some of them
oh oh oh we're running fast
because i can't man i feel like i
definitely need a longer range gun on
this map
all right our raider range all right
let's see what we got here i'll try some
sniping
i don't know how good this sniper is but
we could try it next step
oh wow dwayne colleen
oh
okay i felt like oh that was ours right
that was friendly okay
i'm so bad
no i'm like surprised no one's flanked
me out with
how many sniper shots i've missed from
this singular location
all right nice try thank you again
i probably should have switched the
longer range sooner
i actually don't mind that map though
yeah it's cool
i mean honestly there's a game for
everyone you know
i think like the biggest appeal probably
for cold war though it's gonna be
zombies coming back
and the campaign because i think
honestly like
well for me personally lately like games
that i can play with my friends and
even games that aren't like super sweaty
try hard how many kills can i get and be
on the top of the leaderboard type game
you know that's why games like among us
and like fall guys
and zombies it's like well i'm like ooh
more games i could play with my friends
and like chill and have fun with and
then also have like a side dish
of multiplayer and then like a main
chorus of campaign
it's like there's something for everyone
you know oh
i kind of want to go back to miami
oh yeah let me vote
yeah yeah we could just live vicariously
through this game besides the
like
[Music]
i've been to orlando but i haven't been
to miami ever
oh not me not at all i've only seen it
in like games and movies
yeah 80s moving specifically
i like a lot of the black ops cod games
to be honest i don't think there was
ever a black ops game where i was like
this is super whack
i think i i didn't play much of three
like
one of them i think three had all that
jumping i was like
this isn't for me like the
jet pack jumping i forget what it's
called
someone in the chat said he can't drop
shot in cold war i definitely have been
drop shotting this whole ship
half intentionally and half accidentally
so
[Laughter]
claim denied iv not saying it's a good
thing this is clearly like
a very old cod habit that i've just
carried over to every single kai game
because
sliding though that's uh
little heartbreaking sometimes
we're going to mine
oh man i wish i knew the words because i
do like that song
let's just play when you start this
level it's like partying the city where
the heat is on
that's the most i can contribute to our
sing-along
oh domination i see you
only got smoke grenades i keep trying to
like double sprint
i know me too i'm like i'm going to
completely destroy my analog stick
very secure what is this person
i know where they're coming from
oh they got b already so quickly
i'm still like getting a grasp of this
layout
they're everywhere
um yeah let me just miss every shot on
someone standing completely still
[Laughter]
keep hearing all these gunshots are me
and then i look and then they're
done oh there's no oh okay there's a
window here
i thought i saw someone jump down from
here last time
oh man i am super off
that shouldn't take too long
i am tapping this
lucky me
30 times
[Music]
oh i'm running
[Music]
oh really i think party till the sun
comes out
oh man he almost died
um i suck without a red dog
but my shots they were allergic to my
shots there's nothing i could do
oh no he just ran up on me
i'm going for b
oh never mind nope
that guy left his teammate
i hate that i hate trying to shoot
people at that angle
i can do it
i'm sorry i tried to pull my freaking
artillery out
oh you got me from the other balcony
oh no we're all in here i don't know
[Music]
detected
we were right there we're about to get
that fight
how are the snipers well tyler if i was
good with a sniper i would definitely be
able to tell you
how good they are i use a sniper for
about
four bullets earlier and i hit one and
they died
so to me that feels pretty good
i just have to be honest like sniping's
never really been my strong suit the
only game i was slightly gonna snipe
again was halo 2
with the alien sniper because you could
shoot two shots really fast and like
but if you miss those two shots well
then you're definitely done for a little
while
artillery
[Music]
my eyesight is just not good enough to
shoot through the iron sights
that is the actual truth
[Music]
oh taking charlie
you can always tell it's like shooting a
basketball it's all on release
yeah probably
but i definitely feel it especially when
like there's a lot of them running by
and you can see your
aim to track the other person like
you're trying to like shoot the first
person yeah
oh man this little corner right here is
like not good
oh the
okay flanker think they've finally
switched our spawn i was like
hoping our spawn is switched
okay we're being dominated
oh
yo miami i thought new york rats are
crazy
miami rats go through walls
that's crazy i'm running into walls
right now i can't even
all right we camping it out up here you
guys until i get sniped
am i not the smartest person you guys
have ever seen play this game
they said artillery out and i
immediately ran into the wide open air
i was there too oh crap
oh my god is there two of them here yes
sir
dang there's
my attention gets diverted
what
oh he's like i thought he was chasing
all he was
they're just everywhere i was like i
thought he was chasing me out she wasn't
even the one shooting me
22 and 17.
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh okay yeah you're right dixie this is
definitely not no gta autoimmune
i wish i had gta auto in every game i
would be the best
[Laughter]
no i would still find a way to miss
exactly like i already know
paranoid i got an extended barrel
for this i'm hoping i unlocked a red dot
for this bad boy
yes this it's gonna help with my
horrible aim
i can't wait all right so i think i
actually liked having the stem
i'm a little bit more used to it now and
i can heal
yeah i'm gonna try that out too i'll
keep the frog
field mike it's a little
teeny radar that stays still
i'll stick with the proximity mine
detect enemy upgrades
i'm going to try this but i feel like
it's going to make me freak out
some of these perks say unlocked at
level 29 maybe this goes higher than
you know maybe they're just teasing us
and they're like
see all this stuff you can get once the
game's
up pre-order now
all right we're back on the new map you
guys
let's get it i have a red dot on my
longer range weapon now soon
it's going pretty good
okay hmm no i'm not gonna try sniping no
way
oh yeah no i i tried it for like one
minute
not for me
okay red dot time
yeah for sure east girls i was like i
did do okay though last time with the
shorter range gun on this one but
assault rifle seems like a good idea
i think honestly my biggest struggle now
with like playing
fps games on consoles like now that i've
been playing on pc for a while and like
you know games like valerie and stuff
where you can like move turn around
super fast i'm like now i'm like oh man
i feel like i can't turn around that
fast
but i can't control a higher sensitivity
so i just have to tough it out
i have to understand my own limitations
oh man got some people in the river oh
oh i
see i take the lead oh it's confirmed
okay where'd they go someone's old
i was looking for them we were playing a
little ring around the rosie action
we're losing the adventure
oh let me get that tag
yoink
okay i guess he jumped like right when i
tried to shoot him
dang it
this isn't working
dang it
oh my god there's no way
i felt like i should have killed my
hostile actions
oh
hey they put in work for me right there
crap
did he have martyrdom mistakes were made
mistakes weren't made somebody just
straight up
ended themselves
dang see that's when that fire rate of
the smg would have been like
i'm here to save you yeah
oh
oh my goodness he waited for 10 years
uh okay
oh my gosh behind you he was like hiding
in that corner
not surprising artillery targeting
active
rules yeah right
he's over there
throwing grenades
someone's trying to creep
on us let me get this
ow
oh my goodness
[Music]
yeah it happens to me all the time
see that guy's used to smd i'm about to
go back to mine
that thing is holding me down the last
game
i mean that's always been a cotton thing
though
okay we got that smg now let's go
oh no i hear a chopper is that friendly
or not present
no unfriendly
oh
artillery targeting active
i'm gonna not do that i can't engage in
that fight
oh why is he too clean
see the fiery is just so much better in
this situation
leveled up
[Music]
all right i should have been using the
smg that entire game 100
awesome it's fine though it's fine we
got to learn we got to learn
we got to learn the hard way sometimes
schnitty bigger man jensen over here
okay so i mean honestly i don't have all
the attachments for that gun yet anyways
so
it's probably just not in its peak
because
typically i do like ars more than smgs
and cod games
so me too i'm pretty sure it's just
because i don't have
all the 13 and 15 what a scrub
just kidding um let's see what did i
unlock with that gun
oops
enhanced vertical recoil control
i got the steady aim laser
drop shot hand grip they actually
have it now
yeah so you know good job everyone i
feel like that was a community effort of
years and years
of either loving or hating drop shotting
it got its own attachment now
vandal speed loader
that sounds so fancy yeah
what is good chat i'm like
absorbed right now i haven't really been
like
thanks i've been back to moscow i'm
having fun though i feel like
i haven't been playing as much fps
lately
like this whole past week i finally have
been getting back into it but i was
playing a lot of like
fun silly games like single player games
and adventure games and stuff
yeah i'm like back to sweaty try hard
mode
because i was playing valerian for a
while and i was actually like really
trying to
like get better at it and then i was
like man i need a break
i was like trying to be
all invested need a moment yeah
play some fun stuff it's nice to switch
it up every now and then you guys
all right i'm gonna try the the mp5 this
time
nice nice nice first time i'm still
liking this
momano gun that comes with like the
pre-made glowed outs
but i haven't unlocked it yet oh
we are let's go confirmed
oh as i run directly into a dead end
let's go
i have no idea where i am right now i am
on the outskirts of the map
i don't know why my first instinct is to
run on the outside
my two
oh okay now i'm in a familiar area
oh man i tried
the checker room is the hot spot yeah i
just saw like three people died
okay
oh no this mp5 class doesn't have my
rocket launcher
i can edit live in-game oh yeah that's
one of my favorites
now stop it stop it
the stem is the best
i should change that too i got used to
it i threw a stun
oh my god oh my god oh my god
i tried to run resistance was futile
artillery targeting detective
it was like the one corner i didn't
check too oh okay
i was like scoping out the location i'm
not going that way anymore
not worth i can't win those uh
those battles from windows like that
enemies
i think
yeah right
spy plane inbound
multiple hostel spy planes detected
okay okay okay you know what i'm gonna
try this right here just mine going down
he was trying to like knife me or
something
oh
no that's not the door wait where are my
[Music]
blocks
when they're like right up against a
ledge or something that's their little
brain peeking out
oh my god man i can't
no ah
getting so mixed up in my tacticals
because i've been hopping classes
oh no oh richie i watched
i'll get your tag i'll get your attack
at least
get that guy
oh great
i feel like i should have died right
there and i didn't i'll take that i'll
take that
oh i thought
how did i know they were going to be in
our spawn how did i know
i was like i'll go around this way no
they're not
always
inbound
oh behind us oh my god they keep
flanking us every time
get the win for uncle sam
they're everywhere they're
literally active
incoming artillery
yeah but then when i don't go there i
don't find anybody
so like yo this is music
now i've been in like every play of the
game
this stream what's up with that
that was in one two it was bad
oh level 10 let's go
nice i like it
well at least i unlocked some stuff for
the mp5
to be 13
weird it's like we have different oh no
i mean the milano
oh yeah
does this game have spmn i mean i
wouldn't doubt it
i'm sure
chad was talking about it oh yeah
it's always big it's always i just feel
like it's inevitable to like
not run into somebody is going to be
really good because even if there wasn't
svmm someone would still be making like
smurf accounts and stuff like that
to like go into lower level lobbies
anyways
yeah i'm all for rank but you gotta have
you got a pepper and some
still bass matchmaking all right we're
back on the new map y'all
so far i think we played twice or i did
well once and then i did horrible the
next time so we gotta
equalize that with another good one yeah
it says my average eliminations are 15.
i got it raised
those are rookie numbers oh mine's 16.
and i'm right there with you let's get
them up
exactly
sticking with this one
yeah i guess i'm gonna go back to the
assault rifle nice
yeah i guess the thing about sbm is like
once you do well you're like stuck in
that higher bracket right like they
never
like if you do bad the next game they're
not like all right back to the
crappy lobbies like well you did good
that one time
so just hold that it depends what game
i try not to get in my own head about
stuff like that because i feel like it
makes me play worse
if i if i think about it you know i try
to placebo affect myself
and be like nah it's not in there
there's always going to be people better
than us exactly
oh man oh yeah it's time for me to die i
heard them both coming from both
doors there was nothing i could do
sweet oh no it's confirmed again
i think that was the wrong door oh it's
way over here
two of them three of them wow
they are just constantly running around
well i can't even tell who you guys are
shooting at anymore
i'm just going to pick up tags
oh an ak47
what um
run what the heck
well that guy came all like rambo what's
all that
we're losing this fight um this guy
i can't see there's so many bushes here
i'm just picking up
[Laughter]
this is great i'm very much having the
time of my life right now
the bushes you know i was like if i if i
can't see them they can't see me
so we're in there
he activated my gas that was the first
time i saw it
actually get props
oh good to know that means that's why
all my jumping and craziness was working
because he was trying to snipe me
what
oh my gosh i think i've officially
ruined my controller
i cannot run that well
oh no
i feel like all of my controllers are on
their last legs
they're trapping us
huh
detectives
no i didn't know you behind me
there's so many attacks here i want them
no
yeah let's go
okay
let's give it to my friends
[Music]
oh my god
established overhead got it
yay my guess i farted on somebody
they caught the full effects of only the
gas that i
provide
oh look it's still lingering oh no
no i was so focused on denying the kills
oh that guy's tag name is fart
enemies
oh my god that guy is about to play the
game me again
all right
no no no no yes
that was so crazy all right we won
only face palm right there jeez
what did i tell you he just killed me
today
this guy's going in
okay i missed like the first two shots
so i'm pretty sure
that was the play where he bodied me
but it's all good
all right very nice 21 and 10. all right
i'll take that
i'll take that heck yeah i definitely
didn't pick up enough tags but
i'll take those you take them oh yeah i
unlocked
danger yes gg chat gg
so let's see good wait i'm still level
10.
i felt like that was like at least one
level worth
a game play right there did you get the
blueprint
um level 10 i think you get that little
uh
the 851 you know that little oozy
looking gun
you get a blueprint for it maybe that's
next week
you know that's where i really started
getting lost um
like in general it caught when they
started introducing all these like
blueprints
and different stuff in the barracks
because like you know
i just didn't have the patience to like
sit down and figure out not because i
think
like bad of it just because like
whenever i turn on god i'm like all
right let me get into the game as fast
as i can and just start shooting people
people worry about cosmetics lately and
then i wonder why i'm like getting
bodied because i'm not out here
optimizing my guns or my blueprints
all right let's see it i think
try the stoner from black ops one
okay okay let's see let's try
to go back to this gun but
did i put stem cells in this now i think
oh yeah i did nice nice nice nice
all right so we successfully used the
gas mine a few times that last game
so i'm pretty excited about that
domination oh domination
take the objectives capturing the
objective
taking
um i feel like i should be going that
way yeah
going for b someone's in here
securing bravo okay you're looking that
way i should look this way i guess
he's coming to you what come on
this dude again
i just shot bullets to scare him away
and not necessarily think i was gonna
like this map
i know it feels like so much better on
top of them
no no uh in the middle tube
oh i should have threw it on that side
i was like
i feel like there's not that many people
in this match right now
he's in the tooth again oh wow
oh there
[Music]
ah
this isn't working we're behind
hostile spy plane established overhead
see if that was my smg these
i guess last time we were playing um
tdm and it wasn't exactly
artillery
got two people though oh it was the rc i
thought it was a grenade
these hours thank god
thank you richie
face
um
dang they're all in the trenches down by
armies
i missed everything i hate
trying to contest that angle i'm so bad
at it
okay
all right all right 21 and 11 so far at
half time
not bad oh
close see it's because they had the good
side to start
switching rally points obviously
i think i'm gonna stick with this class
actually
i think we'll go back to the ar
secure the objective
i want to 100 contributed
definitely over here
oh
oh
multiple enemies by playing contacts
no no no
oh i tried everything i could right
there
oh i got my chopper though let's go
chopper time
let's go
let's go chopper i need your help
i need you to intimidate them oh
it's not working
oh i hear the plane farting i don't know
i just haven't killed anyone yet now
oh there we go i got someone finally
they came out of the cave
artillery standing by i mean i don't
blame them
takes out uh
artillery
no he's in the back yeah i just saw him
get blasted with a shotty and that's all
i wanted to see
nice
[Music]
ow
got scared by a piece of metal
oh watch your right richie
my plane's trying to get um
whoa i don't know where he went playing
help me
plane what is my plane doing
i see this guy over here
i don't know where he is
what's the score oh it's over there okay
181 we're close
i should have really switched spots
this score is ours keep it tight and
final numbers we got this
wait wait wait wait you didn't see me
three points left easy game easy life
and let me kill you before it's over oh
i can't never mind
i tried i super tried 38 and 17. i
will take that i mean i'm probably about
to die and just play
the games again oh no that was on our
team nice
we won come back
i know that first half was not that
great for us
but they had us in the first half
yeah all right
so how are you feeling richie are we are
we you to do one more
or i know we're a little bit over time
but i've just been having fun
so same here and i just i almost dropped
a 40 bomb i mean i felt pretty
proud of myself on that one yeah
yes ggchat gg bringing it back
all right this is gonna be our last game
and then we'll be wrapping it up so
hopefully we get
the new map again cartel
yeah that's the one we're here to see oh
it doesn't look like it's in our choices
unfortunately and man people are really
liking satellite
here let me let me bring party back
let's try to get kratz off his last one
okay
sometimes it's nice to have like a
shooter that isn't that
that doesn't have that much of a barrier
you know
because sometimes people just want to
like get in and play and
feel a little good about themselves lord
knows i am not hopping into valor and
getting no 38 kills
i think the highest i've gotten in
valerian was like 30.
and that's huge that was luck
[Laughter]
so it's it's nice
it's nice cod is like a bread and butter
did we somehow get into the same exact
lobby we were just
in it looks like it and i want miami
oh okay nice we beat out the vote with
zero seconds left on the clock
yeah and it seems like you get like a
good amount of points for assists in
this game too
yeah they support that a little more
which is good i always i'm always
getting those assists
okay so domination again
i think uh you know what i think i've
been converted i think cold war has
converted me into an smg users
user
i don't know i'm still on i'm still on
arsenal
i get my stink bomb too on this class so
let's take this
the steak bottle looks perfect
although i'm not sure exactly what it
does but
because i know i was getting a cis for
it so i don't know if it like poisons
them and does like a little bit of
damage over time or it just like stuns
them a little bit
i'll have to like run into somebody
else's or
find five seconds to read the
description
miami look at the boys we about to go
party
domination let's go
capture the objective people are early
shooting
securing
alpha
i might be able to get this no one look
over here and nothing's happening
i got it now watch me die
[Music]
he destroyed me
i was all panicking and he was like let
me show you how it's done
snakes oh no
oh that's how they get up here guys
i'll take that quick triple you know
like those
no i saw one one of our teammates was
going first
there's no way
there is no way oh i can't run okay
there we go
this isn't working we're behind this
isn't working
i'm trying crazy dude you get down here
you try hostile spy plane established
overhead
moving ahead
no no
oh no my controller okay
i'm destroying my analog right now
because it's getting harder and harder
to sprint
oh there's a third one
man we're stuck back here okay let me
try
pinned going all the way
i think this guy saw me running
wow i got stunned and i don't
oh that guy had a vest or something on
i had already got him half-life and i
hit him with a syntax and i just saw a
little armor icon
that was interesting
all right we're gonna try oh
i tried
like oh we can't get out of this
oh no he doesn't see me he won't drop
down he won't drop that oh you did
oh i didn't think you would do it
oh no my controller
my pork your left thumbstick yeah my
left thumbstick is going
out no thanking me
everybody wants to be my friend i feel
so popular oh that's my audio i thought
he was below me
no i almost didn't i got a spy plane
questions by playing this game i must
have a perk on that like lets me keep my
points
oh i'm just trying to run and i can't
well we had a good run you guys so my
controller actually working
come on is that the only one you have oh
man this sucks
there we go i already knew this one was
on its last swim
oh come on come on
[Music]
i was doing too much that last game
is detected i don't think very much
yeah i think like twice but honestly i
don't know if the
notifications are impactful enough to
like get people to stop what they're
doing
and like look at it because yeah it's
like die kind of faster
it's different in multiplayer i can't
run
sucks
i'm like i know they're coming for me
and then i'm just like walking
taking a nice stroll
half time
man that triple kill i got earlier in
this match they were like all right
that's enough for you
time to struggle oh right there boom
i didn't even realize it was me i was
like let's go
yeah let's go we got one best played
this stream let's go switch it up we can
do it
we came back last time oh my gosh i wish
i had
the uh the bravery to buy a scuff
take the objective i've always wanted a
scuff but i just can't bring myself to
pay that much for it
because i feel like the way oh yeah but
your controller is awesome
it's uh it's the first one i ever bought
it was like that modern warfare
it's just i know i manhandle like all of
my controllers
and i just don't want to like
pay that much and then break it because
i know i will oh
oh come on
yo watching myself in the kill cam not
running away from that bullet
oh my god
well i got one rocket on it
it's out oh no please
god this game's impossible to play
without this brand
oh come on i believe in you there we go
b
[Music]
well like i might as well just crosstalk
oh that's my teammate why is his name oh
my god this guy
like put a bunch of spaces at the end of
his name so that his name is not
above his head oh that's annoying
i for a second thought it was the enemy
but it was actually our teammate because
his name is
also great oh
jeez
over there
no oh no
oh god i cannot run i got that sniper
over b
oh my god
oh i'm a level 13 that means i just um
come on i just unlocked the gun i'm
using right now
hopefully
[Music]
oh i got stunned
wow okay i hit him with like 30 shots
ah come on i just want to run your last
breath
i mean i would never say that in real
life i can't run in real life but
right now i definitely would say
better maybe it's just trying to reflect
my real life capabilities
putting an artillery over b although it
won't help
oh dang
my melon defeats all right
yeah we just have to hold that l
because i wouldn't be able to play
another one right now even if i wanted
to
but it was still fun actually yeah
i like this map right well chad there
you go we played a bit of the beta with
you guys
it is going to be up for like the rest
of the weekend we have
on gamespot.com right now more
information on which platform has beta
access
and when because it all depends on when
you pre-ordered where you pre-ordered
and if you pre-ordered so be sure to
check that out
thanks for hanging out with us thanks
for playing some cod
and hope you guys enjoyed and we'll see
you next time maybe next week because
there's going to be a brand new game
mode
coming out next week so um we might be
back for more
never know hopefully we'll see you then
and maybe i'll have a
better controller and i'm sorry that i
broke them
all right you guys peace out it was fun
thanks
so much and goodbye
bye